it's not often that actors get to say
goodbye to a character on his own terms
especially when it comes to big-budget
superhero action fests more often than
not an actor's movie flops or he decides
to not come back for the sequel or
Merciless producers kill characters off
to make room for more exciting heroes
but in the case of Wolverine Hugh
Jackman got the chance to go out with a
bang in 2017 slogan and while the ending
was pretty straightforward in a lot of
ways there are definitely some lingering
questions both of them the story and in
the real world that are worth discussing
Poppaea claws light a cigar and watch
out for spoilers while we test out some
theories to try to explain the ending of
Logan what was across the border
throughout the film
Logan embarked on a quest to deliver
Laura to Eden someplace in North Dakota
that would provide sanctuary for her and
every other mutant kid who escapes the
transition program run by dr. rice
Logan's skeptical because he thinks it
came out of a comic book only to
discover that Eden was real and that the
kids were going to Trek a few miles
through the woods to make it over the
Canadian border to safety only we never
quite find out just what was across the
border obviously something was waiting
for them up there and it was powerful
and important enough that Rice PS and
the Reavers had to nab the kids before
they crossed the border if you're a
longtime x-men fan you may already know
what or who were obliquely referring to
Canada powerful mutants Alpha Flight
that's right it's Canada's premier super
team of mutants Alpha Flight was sort of
a combination of the x-men and the
Avengers but covered in maple syrup and
always carrying hockey sticks in shorts
there's plenty of reason to believe that
some sorts of cinematic adaptation of
Alpha Flight was waiting to receive and
rescue the kids across the northern
border and because Alpha Flight has
usually been depicted as working as part
of the Canadian government's it makes
sense that they wouldn't legally be
allowed to cross into American territory
to rescue the x-23 kids directly but
once they're in Canadian jurisdiction
they'd be able to blast any Reaver
stupid enough to follow and there's
plenty of real-world evidence that Alpha
Flight was waiting under the shade of
some pine trees for the kids for
starters 20th Century Fox has
we'll only barely scratched the surface
in terms of characters that can use to
build its comic book cinematic universe
Fox has a movie rights to pretty much
every character associated with the
x-men that clearly includes Alpha Flight
which debuted as a partial explanation
of Wolverines them mysterious backstory
in x-men 120 back in 1979 so this point
of the movie franchise has made only
very oblique references to Alpha Flight
most notably in an on-screen Easter Egg
in X to x-men United but in February
2017 x-men producer Simon Kinberg told
comic-book comm that there are potential
plans to develop an X flight movie
that's likely either a slip of the
tongue and that he meant to say alpha
flights or the franchise is being
changed to brand it closer to the rest
of the films and the franchise but
either way don't be surprised to hear
that the follow up to Logan is a start
of an alpha flight related franchise and
less Generation X we don't know anything
about the woman on the other end of the
radio drawing rector's chat with whoever
was in Canada waiting for the kids maybe
it was one of the members of Alpha
flights or maybe it was another famous
x-men character who's long been
associated with Wolverine Jubilee in the
90s the Generation X series was a more
modern take on the new mutants team that
had morphed into x-force by that point
Jubilee who at times has been kind of an
unofficial sidekick for Wolverine in the
comics was a main component of the team
as was the White Queen Emma Frost both
characters have been established in the
x-men films in different ways and the
franchise's murky timeline make it
entirely possible that a woman on the
radio could have been either one while
this isn't quite as fun as the Alpha
Flight very it's just as possible at the
end of Logan could be setting up a
possible Generation X film with a whole
batch of young mutants to learn under
the instruction of these veteran
characters the eulogy after Laura buries
Logan in the woods of North Dakota she
delivers a eulogy that a while
meaningful might have left some viewers
confused don't feel bad it was way easy
to get distracted by the delightful
mayhem throughout the movie so you may
have missed this
Laura was quoting the closing monologue
from Shane which she watched in the
hotel room with Xavier know living with
for the killing there's no going back
right and Ron's brand ban sticks and
that wasn't just a random reference of
course Shane was a Western about a
gunslinger putting his Spurs on again
for one final fights sounds familiar
are you run on home to your mother tell
her tell her everything's alright there
aren't any more guns in town x marks the
spot after all the kids have left
Laura picks up the little wooden cross
some marks Logan's grave and tilts it on
its side marking an X but that's a
pretty obvious not too well the x-men
but it's also a pretty beautiful quiet
statement about the kind of guy
Wolverine was throughout all these
movies the cross at the gravesite is
meant to reflect a person's faith in God
in something higher than them obviously
Logan wasn't much of a Christian but he
was an x-man and he spent his life
fighting for the betterment of mutant
kind and the ideas of Charles Xavier the
fact that he devoted the final years of
his life taking care of Xavier shows
that despite his insistence that he
didn't care about much he believed in
Xavier and his dream of peace and
prosperity more than he might have
admitted resurrection now you can't keep
a good hero down Hugh Jackman has
clearly said goodbye to the role that
made him famous with Logan so chances
are pretty slim that he'll put the claws
on again but this is Wolverine he's on
par with Batman Superman and spider-man
in terms of recognizability and
popularity he's an incredibly valuable
brand to Fox and he'd be crazy if you
thought a little thing like Hugh
Jackman's retirement might stop them
from putting Wolverine in more movies
this is definitely not the last time
we'll see Wolverine on film and frankly
don't even believe that Jackman's has
done as he says yes they always come
back man if an old dude like Spock can
come back to life Wolverine a super
mutant with a super healing factor
certainly can
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]